let's go next um all right i mean maybe
against my better judgment i'm curious
what he has to say let's go to jimmy
from philly jimmy you are on the air
hey david how are you doing i'm doing
well thank you jimmy
so david i just wanted to say that
listen to that prosecutor kind of
reminded me of when i talk to you
i'm sorry can your which prosecute what
are you talking about jimmy
they're listening to the prosecutor in
uh the kyle case oh college
yes reminds me what other kyle is there
david my god you've been doing this for
eight hours
um
you're good to throw me for a loop david
yeah like
uh uh yeah
listen to that prosecutor reminds me of
speaking to you because he was trying to
trap kyle into saying different things
which is the same thing you do with me
and at the end of the day when i don't
say it you just lie and say that i said
it
i thought you were going to say that the
prosecutor reminded me of me
because of his incredible poise
preparation and how articulate he was
oh well how about when he basically
disregarded the judge's orders many
times which then pissed off the judge
yeah and most of your chat thinks that
he's biased towards kyle no he purposely
pissed off the judge
and then you got a reaction from the
judge i mean it's very clear i mean he's
disregarded the judge's orders numerous
times you can't do that in the courtroom
surprising to hold him in contempt well
jimmy i really appreciate your legal
insights what do you expect in terms of
the verdict
oh i i tend to agree with you i i think
that uh i don't think that he will be
found guilty of murder but
at one gun charge maybe he maybe he gets
found guilty on that i'm not sure
you know i don't think the kid goes to
prison clearly the judge ain't going to
hurt him
right
what's going on at your place jimmy
it sounds wild there's chimes and
different elements
what's what's happening at your place it
sounds crazy today
hold on sure somebody's trolling me
david give me a second oh my pleasure
things happening in real time i i don't
understand why this is happening
well i'm sorry oh my god jimmy what is
it i don't know why i don't know why
this is happening
okay what's for dinner tonight jimmy
uh well i just ordered
ordered a
um
oh uh uh what would you call it uh oh
jesus
um chicken caesar
salad oh okay do you like it with uh
with the anchovies or without
no anchovies no i ordered tomatoes with
david for the life of me i cannot
understand
why this is going on
do you mean why people eat fish or what
what i know music
okay all right jimmy thank you hey jimmy
i do want to move on but it's always a
pleasure speaking i'm sorry david
okay all right there's jimmy from philly
delivering
um
absolutely critical and incisive legal
opinion on the kyle rittenhouse case
one of our sponsors is four sigmatic the
company best known for their delicious
mushroom coffee four sigmatics mushroom
coffee is organic fair trade single
origin arabica coffee with both lion's
mane and chaga mushrooms chaga mushrooms
have actually been shown to have
potential in supporting the immune
system in peer-reviewed studies i've
been drinking four sigmatic coffee a lot
lately it actually doesn't taste
anything like mushrooms it just tastes
like any delicious coffee but it's
really easy on my stomach doesn't give
me any jittery feeling or a midday crash
and they have over 20 000 five star
reviews and best of all if you don't
love it you'll get 100 percent of your
money back because they stand behind
their product you've got nothing to lose
by giving it a try
four sigmatic is giving my audience up
to 40 percent off and free shipping when
you go to
4sigmatic.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video